llegó el momento de repasar toda la
prensa internacional con rosa pérez más
euros a bienvenida muy buen día
empezamos con el tema diplomático del
día el boicot de eeuu a estos juegos
olímpicos de invierno que se van a
desarrollar en beijing el próximo año
2022 vamos a verlo por la prensa china y
también por la prensa estadounidense
empezamos con la china con el south
china morning post que titula la casa
blanca confirma el boicot diplomático de
los olímpicos de beijing 2022 rosa
buenos días exacto y de aquí el verbo
con firma raúl porque ya veníamos
comentando este posible boicot desde
hacía semanas pero pues definitivamente
se ha confirmado y por lo tanto este
medio chino lo que hace es recoger por
un lado las declaraciones de la portavoz
de la casa blanca james aquí que dice no
asistiremos pero los atletas tendrán
todo nuestro apoyo por otro lado también
han recoge la frase del portavoz del
ministerio de exteriores de exteriores
chino zhao liang que dice beijing tomará
contra partidas contundentes como nos
comentaba nuestro corresponsal en
beijing y por último él vista por sí
mismo afirma que este movimiento
seguro que editorial deteriorará todavía
más la relación ya por sí es bastante
complicada entre washington y beijing
vamos ahora con el segundo
enfoque digamos que en el nivel sam's el
lado estadounidense destaca eeuu enviará
funcionarios a los juegos olímpicos de
beijing un artículo de solán cano jones
exacto y el periodista lo que dice es
que esta es una bofetada a china por sus
vulneraciones de los derechos humanos
particularmente contra la población
uigur en la región de xinjiang pero
específica también es citando distintas
voces dentro de este texto que haya pues
representantes tanto demócratas como
republicanos que piden un boicot
completo porque recordemos que eeuu si
mandará a sus atletas como estábamos
comentando simplemente los diplomáticos
no asistirán a los juegos pero el
periodista recalca que anteriormente
tampoco es que hayan ha cambiado el
tablero internacional los boicot a los
juegos olímpicos
como último boicot total que se hizo en
1980 bajo la presidencia de jimmy carter
a los juegos olímpicos en este caso de
verano en moscú como protesta por la
presencia militar soviética en
afganistán y por último este texto
termina pues con la puntualización de
que este anuncio llega unos días antes
de que se celebre esta cumbre por la
democracia no que ha organizado el
presidente de eeuu joe biden en la que
ha invitado a 100 países entre los
cuales pues no figura china vamos a
cambiar ahora completamente tema rosa
vamos con al yazira que abre con lo que
dice uganda planea reabrir las escuelas
el próximo año pero quien va a regresar
eso es y es que el presidente de uganda
yoweri museveni anunció que en enero de
2022 se van a reabrir los centros
educativos en el país que cerraron en
marzo de 2020 y al yazira señala que se
trata de uno de los cierres más largos
del mundo y básicamente las autoridades
locales web estiman que el 30 por ciento
de los estudiantes no van a regresar a
las aulas por distintos motivos entre
ellos pues embarazos adolescentes
matrimonios forzados o trabajo infantil
en minas o plantaciones y entre otros
testigos este artículo recoge el de
florence negaba a una chica de 15 años
que desde marzo de 2020 ha tenido dos
hijos y ha sido expulsada de su casa y
como comentábamos pues no es un caso
aislado se estima que situaciones
parecidas pueden llegar a un 30 por
ciento de los chicos y chicas que
estaban escolarizados en uganda antes de
la pandemia y bien pues lo que destacan
unidades sindicales de profesores del
país es que pues este encierro de los
centros educativos particularmente en
este país ha hecho más mal que bien
porque pues como en todo el mundo eso sí
raúl pues ha agravado las desigualdades
y en este mapa que figura en el artículo
vemos pues a los países más afectados
por los cierres educativos y vemos
bastantes países aquí de la región
latinoamericana vamos ahora con un tema
investigación de un crimen que se
cometió rosa aquí en colombia durante el
paro nacional y que le dio la vuelta al
país vamos a ver qué titula pues como
titula este esta pieza investigación que
dice la pieza que faltaba en el crimen
de lucas bizarros eso es este es un
esfuerzo colectivo de distintos medios
de investigación 070 con evelyn cut y
otros que intentan reconstruir los
momentos previos a la muerte de lucas
biglia que recordemos era un joven
estudiante de pereira que fue bueno le
arrebataron la vida no se sabe todavía
quién en el marco de las protestas del
paro nacional de aquí de colombia
particularmente el 5 de mayo de 2021 y
lo que hacen estos medios de
comunicación es una reconstrucción
basada en las cámaras de seguridad que
grabaron el escenario así como con
vídeos encontrados en las redes sociales
y testigos de presentes el día de los
hechos y además hacen una reconstrucción
en 3d y de hecho hemos querido
seleccionar nada 30 segundos de esta
reconstrucción y de este vídeo para qué
hagamos una idea de qué va esta pieza y
para invitar a nuestra audiencia a mirar
el reportaje completo que dura 20
minutos si les parecen vamos a las
imágenes
es probable que el último disparo
ocurrió cuando ya lukas estaba tendido
en el piso
en el vídeo de la cámara de seguridad
vemos una moto rondando el área minutos
antes del crimen
la primera vez que la vemos es a las
siete y veinte con nueve segundos
conduciendo en sentido este lleva un
pasajero y las luces apagadas finalmente
lo que concluye esta investigación es
que se trató de un crimen premeditado y
coordinado y se pregunta por qué ni la
fiscalía ni la policía ha hecho públicas
las investigaciones que consideran
necesarias para el acceso a la justicia